- He was saying some really mean
and just not true things
about me on social media.
So I printed out screenshots of it
and I brought his hoodies to his house
and I taped all of those
screenshots to the package
so that his mom could read them.
- [Group] Wow.
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] We brought
together seven people,
who've been cheated on.
- My name's Tidiane and
I've been cheated on.
- My name's Angel and
- Hi, my name is Morgan
and I have been cheated on.
- Hi I'm Mary Anne and
I've been cheated on.
- Hi my name is Vivian
and I've been cheated on.
- Hi my name is Avi, and
I've been cheated on.
- Hi my name is Erin and
I have been cheated on.
- [Narrator] One of them is a cheater.
If the group discovers who the liar is,
they'll split a cash prize.
If the liar survives,
they win the entire prize.
(cash register rings)
Who is the odd one out?
- Hi everyone.
- [Group] Hi!
- How's everyone doing?
- What's going on?
- Good.
- Great.
- So, who's cheated?
(group laughs)
- Straight off the bat.
- Great way to ask.
- [Mary Anne] Who's it gonna be?
- I took psychology class,
and what they said is
when you talk to people
look into their eyes
and ask 'em a question.
So I can ask the question to everybody,
or if some somebody wants to ask?
- The mole would say that tho.
- You can see their pupils?
- Like they dilate a little.
- That's crazy.
- And stuff like that, so it's-
- He took on a leadership
role immediately.
So maybe he was asking those questions
so that he could give
his prepared response
to kind of try to convince us.
- I was gonna go straight
for the kill question.
Like, do you guys think
cheating is like a,
like, could you be redeemed after that?
- Oh man.
- I personally don't think so.
- I think it's very nuanced.
I think that most of the time, no.
But also like for me,
I was cheated on twice
but one of the times I was 15
and it's like, do I think that that person
is gonna be a cheater their entire life?
I don't think so,
we were kids.
- Yeah.
- Sorry, I was gonna say there
is also kind of a gradient.
Like, I mean, for me, I'm
not a very jealous person.
If you're drunk at a bar
and you kiss a stranger
and you feel bad about it,
like I can swallow that.
But if you're fully like
went home with someone,
like at each level did not
stop a hookup from happening,
which is what happened to me.
- She said something about like,
if you just kiss somebody at like a bar
or something like that, you know,
it's not that bad or something.
So that right there was still considered
like a form of cheating to me.
So I thought she was the mole herself.
- For me, it depends on the person
and how much they're willing
to make it work and change,
you know?
- Mm-hmm.
- Cause I do believe in change,
but if they're like making excuses,
so it's just like, oh, I'm sorry, babe
but it'll never happen again.
- Yeah.
- And then they like change
for like that period of time
and then it happens again.
You know, it's kind of like,
what is your commitment
to your change?
- Or if they try to downplay
how bad it was?
- Yeah.
- I also think it depends
on like who cares,
'cause I know some people
care a lot about cheating
and others that don't.
Some people will find
that more redeemable.
- I feel like most people would
care about cheating though.
- Yeah.
(bell ringing)
(upbeat music)
- I just felt like he was very confident
but in a way that kind of felt scripted.
(upbeat music continues)
- Tidiane said that stuff
about not everyone cares about cheating.
And I was like, that's a little off to me.
(upbeat music continues)
- [Narrator] We actually have a tie.
The tie is between Avi and Tidiane.
Tidiane, do you wanna
go ahead and go first?
- I really didn't get
that much time to talk.
So I was just kind of like
letting you guys talk it all out.
I got cheated on when I was in college
and I actually found it very
interesting what you said.
Yeah, you.
- Okay.
- Because you were saying that like,
you could forgive somebody
who was like just hooking up
if they were just like a
random stranger kissing
and that's actually what my ex to me.
- Oh, I'm sorry about that.
- So I just thought it was interesting.
(bell ringing)
- Well, I actually grew
up in a traditional
Indian family household,
so the way I was brought up
was to always treat women with respect.
For me, actually, I have
a very interesting story
how I found out that my
girlfriend was cheating on me.
I saw a Facebook profile picture
of her with another dude.
She's like, oh, we've been
best friends for two years.
Come to find out, they've
been dating for two years.
- What?
- So that's my story.
(bell ringing)
(group talking indistinctly)
(intense music)
(buzzer ringing)
- Sorry.
- Yeah, I knew that coming in
I was gonna be eliminated first.
I'm just seen as somebody who's a player.
It just all just kind of
like made sense to me.
- Did you do anything crazy
when they cheated on you?
- (claps) I was about to. (laughs)
I was about to, when I got cheated on,
I actually kept it to myself for a week.
- Oh my God.
- I know it was hard.
I don't know why I tortured myself,
but it was because I was so pissed
that I wanted to plan out revenge.
- Yeah.
- And I just ended up slipping
in one of our arguments.
- We actually did, I
personally actually dealt
with not really revenge,
but so I hit up that guy
'cause I found him on
social media, you know?
And found out that he's
been dating for a long time.
- That's what I was trying to,
I was trying to find the girl.
- So I told him to set up a date with her
at Cheesecake Factory.
And I was like, I'm just gonna show up.
- What an arena.
- Dude that was my idea!
You lived out my dream.
- So I literally showed up.
So they're having their date.
- I'm just kidding.
- I'm like this is fully
planned, I walk in there
and then literally she
just goes immediately
to just bawling out crying
and stuff like that.
She's like, I'm so sorry, I'm this, but-
- If that really did happen, I'm so sorry.
But like that was just like crazy to me.
It was like this perfect
cinematic masterpiece
of like, I wish I could do that.
Not entirely wish it,
but you know what I mean.
- For me, I was actually trying
to do a long distance relationship.
A week in to him being
away, he cheated on me.
- Oh my God.
- And he was saying some really mean
and just not true things
about me on social media.
So I printed out like screenshots of it
and I brought his hoodies to his house,
dropped them off in his parents' house,
and I taped all of those
screenshots to the package
so that his mom could read them.
- Wow!
- Good for you.
- Wow, good for her.
- I think I was just so
caught up in the anger.
You know what I mean?
- Exactly, I know.
- I know what you mean.
- And the frustration.
It's just like, I couldn't
really see clearly.
In those moments, I wanted
him to feel what I felt.
- It's hard.
- It's absolutely hard.
- It's something hard to deal with.
- It's really tough.
- So I just wanted to know,
what your guy's definition of cheating is?
That was like on my mind, you know?
How would you guys define cheating?
- I think, I don't know,
I think it's a definition
that is really up to like the individual.
I think it can change a lot.
And a lot of people
probably agree with that.
Like it's really up to
someone's boundaries,
but obviously you know,
like the typical things
like hooking up with someone else,
really flirting with someone else,
continuing like situation-type
relationship with somebody
would be cheating in my eyes.
- Yeah, there's emotional
cheating, physical cheating.
- That's what I was gonna
piggyback off of that.
- Can I clarify what I in the last round?
Just cause I would hate to discount anyone
who that was their experience of like,
my offhand comment of like
kissing a stranger in a bar.
I don't know, I'm sorry if
that is what happened to you.
That's just something that
I'm not a very jealous person.
There are some acts that are cheating,
but that I know that
given the right person,
the right relationship,
I would personally be able to forgive.
It's not black and white for me.
- It's also the intention, I think.
Because if someone do it
with malicious intention,
like if they really wanna harm you
or they really wanna end the relationship
but they're still in the relationship.
- Mm-hmm, yeah.
- So I think,
that's something you need
to have an introspection
and see like, well this is bad.
- I feel like especially within,
and I don't wanna like be the
hater to my generation at all,
but I just feel like in our day and age
for like relationships, we
don't discuss boundaries
firm enough of what everybody thinks
their definition of cheating is.
But no, I feel like especially
when you get cheated on,
especially at a younger age,
we let emotions control
us a little bit more.
- [Group] Yeah.
- And I feel like
doing something crazier is
just a little bit more rational
in people's heads at that age.
(bell ringing)
(upbeat music)
- He played out that ideal story
of like getting back at your ex.
It could also just be
like the typical things
that you see at the movies.
(upbeat music continues)
- [Narrator] And again,
we have another tie.
It's between Avi and Erin.
- Yeah, I was actually pretty surprised
that I was in another tie again.
- I was being a bit too
casual (laughs) about it.
So I was not surprised that I was chosen.
I was living in the same town
as my ex and I had to move.
And so we knew that we had a deadline.
And then when I moved,
we decided to have a
three week buffer period
where we would do a long distance.
And then we had a
deadline for our breakup.
Two days before that deadline,
they went to a pride event and
hooked up with somebody else.
If you're gonna cheat, let
the other person go first.
Don't let 'em sit through
that, 'cause that sucks.
(bell ringing)
- Yeah, I mean just kind of
piggy-back off what I was saying
just the way I was brought up.
I don't see cheating
as a good thing at all.
If you had to put yourself
in the other person's shoes.
If you do cheat, think
about like how much damage
that can cause to them.
Because like I know when I got cheated on,
I didn't even get into a relationship
for at least like six months to a year.
(bell ringing)
- [Narrator] You guys are
actually going to group up
and decide on one person
that you want to eliminate.
(group whispering)
(intense music)
- Okay.
(intense music continues)
(buzzer ringing)
- Okay.
You guys might have voted
the wrong person. (laughs)
- Sorry Avi, sorry.
- I said a story about
actually how things unraveled.
It did honestly look pretty cinematic.
(laughs) So I think that's why
people thought that I was the mole.
And any non-cheaters can
slide in my DMs. (laughs)
- [Narrator] Raise your
hand if you think the mole
is still in the box and you
would like to continue the game.
- I couldn't focus on all of
the people that were playing,
but I felt that the people that
were out were not the moles.
- [Narrator] All right, that
means that the game ends here.
If the lights turn green that
means you voted the mole out
and you all win!
However, if the lights turn red,
that means the mole is still
in the box and you lose.
(intense music)
(group gasps)
- I knew it, I knew it!
- Will the mole please reveal themselves?
In three,
two,
one.
- (exhales) Sorry guys.
- What? (laughs)
- Sorry.
- I feel so dumb.
- Oh, don't, don't.
So I've been on both sides.
(crying) I've been cheated
on and I've been the cheater.
When I first (sniffles)
applied to do this,
I had like only one intention in mind,
is to give purpose to my pain.
I was cheated on in college. (sniffles)
He was the first person
who ever made me feel
like I was enough. (crying)
So then when he cheated on me,
I felt like he took that
away from me. (sniffling)
And I've been struggling
with it ever since.
For me, the greatest pain
wasn't being cheated on,
but being the person
who inflicted the pain
that I already knew so well.
You knew better, why didn't you do better?
You know, so that was
just like, ah, it just hit
- It felt like she was all of our exes,
telling us what we needed to hear.
And I mean, we couldn't have asked
for a better mole than Mary Anne,
because she really gave
us that moment to heal.
And she was a great like surrogate
for everyone who had been hurt
to get that kind of closure, I suppose.
- So Mary Anne, the floor is yours.
- Even though I won, I-
I don't wanna take it.
I actually wanna give this prize money
to the people who've been cheated on.
So if I can invite everyone
that was with me, right?
To come up stage, we're gonna
win this celebratory money,
and I'm gonna give this to you guys.
(emotional violin music)
So this money is going to you guys,
I'm not gonna keep any of it. (laughs)
You guys can just buy
me drink, if you want.
(group laughing)
Everyone's hands in,
on three, two, one.
♪ Money, money, money, money ♪
- I'll throw it.
- Gonna throw it up in the air.
- All right, we're all
gonna pick it up in the end,
but you know, why not?
We're just gonna do the little, bam!
(group cheering)
- To trauma!
- (laughs) To trauma.
(group laughing)